les précisions de notre envoyé spécial
cyril payen
s'est résolument là une bataille qui va
être déterminante ce sont ces le front
nord ouest en fait c'est un désaxé
stratégiques les plus importantes pour
refermer ce siège et qui semble
inéluctable sur la capitale ukrainienne
nous avons pu partir en voiture avec des
volontaires le doigt sur la gâchette il
y à une dizaine de kilomètres qui
séparent le pont ce pont qui est devenue
célèbre puisque c'est le pont qui mène
au centre de kiev dans ce ces deux
districts du nord-ouest bon qui a été
saboté le 25 le 25 février par les
forces du chrétienne pour empêcher
l'arrivée des chars et alors là cette
ville d'hier pink est une ville normale
résidentiel où des dizaines de milliers
de résidents on le sent bien il y a
encore quinze jours un peu plus de
quinze jours et bien vivait une vie tout
à fait normale d'impayés aux frontières
de l'europe un pays développé là le
temps s'est arrêté il y avait des
cadavres qui ont été laissées en pleine
rue des civils tués alors que les
volontaires nous emmener au front au les
chars russes étaient bien visibles à
moins de 200 m c'est 200 m ar pin alors
que les combats font rage et repris ce
matin c'est 200 m de présence des chars
russes ailleurs pin ça veut dire très
concrètement 15 km depuis la le centre
de kiev où on se trouve et on sent que
cette pression militaire s'accentue même
évidemment si elle est lente même s'il
ya une mobilisation importante sur ses
fonds du nord-ouest et on le sait
ailleurs dans le pays cette pression ce
sens il y a eu des raids aériens cette
nuit à l'aube à 4 heures du matin il y a
eu des graves que des longues coupures
d'électricité
il y a moins de chauffage maintenant
notamment dans les habitations où il ya
encore des ddd résident donc on sent
bien que c'est cette ville va commencer
à être déjà épuisé avant même que le
siège ne commence et j'ajoute qu'il fait
extrêmement froid il fait moins 10 dans
les rues donc tout ça ne facilite
évidemment pas
l'évacuation l'esprit de résistance
n'ont pu penser aussi que d'ailleurs du
côté des temps que russe de le ddd
soldats russes qui sont à l'offensive la
partie non plus n'est pas nécessairement
gagner parce que c'est extrêmement
compliqué on le sait comme conditions
climatiques comme conditions sur le
terrain